we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we're going to go to our next caller
from the three one five area code caller
from three one five welcome what's your
name where are you calling from and
what's your question today hi guys my
name is J I'm calling from upstate New
York
alright what's on your mind I I'd like
to read you a little statistic from
Huffington Post and wondering if I can
get your thoughts on there's a hairdo as
a the Supreme Court's temporary lift on
Trump's travel ban right
shortly after Tuesday Supreme Court
ruling the New York Times reported that
the administration is also considering
slashing the annual refugee settlement
cap to below 50,000 the lowest it would
be since 1980 when Barack Obama was in
office he raised it to 110,000 from
70,000 now my question is what do you
think this accomplishes other than the
racists in charge keeping brown people
out of the United States well it
accomplishes the thinly veiled notion of
keeping us safe right because this is
all that that's the undertone even
though the white nationalists and the
racists have been very clear that their
understanding Donald Trump's coded
language incredibly clearly there's
still been this sort of faux I don't
know call it like a costume or a
cloaking of sorts that this is all
because we're a country of law and order
and we're gonna be safe and we're gonna
be orderly and everybody's gonna go out
and then they're gonna come back in
through the big beautiful door or
whatever the case may be but of course
the white nationalists they get it loud
and clear so I completely agree with you
that in practice it accomplishes very
little other than just perpetuating the
sort of white supremacist undertones of
the Trump administration but it does at
least on paper allowed Trump to claim
that he's doing some of what he promised
to do during the campaign but it's
ridiculous I mean clearly you see
through it Jay it sounds like yeah
under the veil of security I guess
you're right it does look good on paper
but this this is such a red flag of
racism to me
of course it it should scream to a
higher level of the media to me yeah it
should but you know there are so many
constant scandals and atrocities being
said that individually a lot of stuff
that that should be major breaking news
just barely makes a blip in the media
radar because we're constantly hearing
about so much but you're absolutely
right and it's all part of the same
thing and of course where is the
evidence that refugees in the United
States are this grave risk and
committers of crime right I mean we
don't have that evidence that's that's
what is often forgotten in this exactly
I agree all right Jay thanks for the
call really appreciate it and on that
note we will take a break 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 is the number we will take more calls
right after this